the eh-2-zed of isms libertarianism the
nine most terrifying words in the
English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to help the
words are the then US President Ronald
Reagan back in 1986 Reagan's mockery of
a very government he headed tapped into
widespread American support for
political philosophy that grew
throughout the 20th century his most
vocal champions such as Senator Rand
Paul and the Koch brothers on the
political fringes but libertarian
thinking has influenced mainstream
politics from Ahnold reagan's attacks on
government to Margaret Thatcher's desire
to roll back the frontiers of estate
libertarianism as roots go back much
further though as their name suggests
libertarians see their philosophy as
embodying the principles of individual
liberty promoted by the European
enlightenment and American independence
in the 18th century political
libertarianism is particularly at home
in the USA which celebrates the pioneer
values of self-reliance and rugged
individualism key among these is the
principle of the self or ownership your
life belongs to you and no one else
hence the Liberty they defend is what
philosopher Isaiah Berlin called
negative freedom freedom from
interference by others especially
governments libertarians regard all
government as a necessary evil
they favor a minimal state which the
leading libertarian philosopher Robert
Nozick said should be limited to the
narrow function of protection against
force theft fraud enforcement of
contracts and so on such a minimal state
would not even provide public services
such as health and education for
libertarians welfare states create
dependency and stifle initiative these
principles make libertarians very
critical of taxation Nosek words so far
as to say that taxation of earnings from
labor is on a par with forced labor
although libertarians tend to be
politically right-wing there was also a
fairly strong tradition of left
libertarianism such as that advocated by
Canadian philosopher Hillel Steiner
he claims that no one has a right to
claim ownership of common goods such as
land
with an equal distribution of natural
resources for everyone there would be
sufficient equality while leaving people
as free as possible to decide how to
live their own lives
critics of libertarianism argue that we
are not truly free unless we have access
to things like decent housing health
care and education we could only have
this positive freedom as Berlin called
it in a state that provides services and
redistribute some wealth libertarianism
may not be well known as a philosophy
but its spirit is invoked every time
people attack big government or the
nanny state it's probably the most
influential political philosophy most
people have never heard of